[ __ ] how I got my name
welcome back foots in the more doctor
mode Deccan Jones Jones way go now you
bros wanted me to finish it and I'm
doing it
only problem is I feel kind of nauseous
like I want to throw up or something so
I apologize
the commentary isn't as good as it
supposed to be and here are you hell out
there cancer I'll just go over here hey
doesn't scare me when I don't have that
room ha
I found your only weakness stash I'll
slap you let me slap hahaha oh man that
felt good after all the pain he caused
me I don't know why but kind of want
this music in the back this it's kind of
difficult dr. moon you basically need to
be half Korean at least at Lee what are
you doing wah wah don't know I'm a ghost
all right
where the hell am I
trihard face hi what HP oh this brings
back so many memories I remember I said
Hal our Politis and then you killed me
that was cried to come weird rendered
thumb something I try to get released
when you crazy back and I'm sure that
shames are still supposed to sound like
hey baby girl
that's what you get for trying to have
me a lot of girl try to help me but
you're not allowed all right your store
that coming from
back up back up back up oh how they
selling and I then rip potato whatever
is chicken here we can find something
hey mo found that [ __ ] didn't even have
to go around the vowel shift here we're
gonna try some different hey another one
of you back up shut your ass and that's
how you die straightening steel
straightening skills driven skills per
fall hey do my laundry while I kill
zombies and that love me
alright I have a plan and I don't know
if equal life the guy has scissored I
would call in my sister to see Frank BAM
baby and it was like about I should
probably reload before I went done more
ammo
sweet baby lumen I get this candid kind
of a production I'm I'm aside I'm a
suicide told me I haven't excused today
don't let don't beg back back up I tried
to get for being Facebook gonna go in
here a loader stuck I don't even know
the objective of this I guess it's like
going back back in pole to me unknown
and I feel like oh no oh [ __ ] me
okay let's do this for Lady gaga yes you
like a boom dad was not expected but I
did sneak past him
I did do it I did do it what that's not
a nice business save come on don't tell
me
oh [ __ ] please right there isn't it how
is born there what the [ __ ]
it's like a nightmare don't do - I don't
know where I saved last I wasn't just
what that [ __ ] now I hope you'd buy it
confused me okay we're here say Sai and
we go see R sin here right not cheating
cuz I'm thinking about Justin evilly no
I'm not what I think about Facebook
that's round for my mom
that's for my grandmother who sign up
for Facebook you know how annoying that
watch god damn she kept poking me for so
long
alright it's not just me
not scare with sound ah [ __ ] me my
hatred for the chainsaw guy I wonder if
you could kill him that would be pretty
though
let's look back not even that what about
that exchange files I changed no guy
would be all like openness mother-effer
all right whoa whoa whoa
I would not be happy if you were my son
I would be disappointed maybe there's a
memo someone shooting me it's more bad
bad people I don't know why they are if
I was Abed I would be happy I would be a
dream come true I don't know what whoa
ice giant
wow that's like a million of you calm
down everyone she'll pal
she'll Pelphrey shield bills and the
others part of town not here my god damn
it they want from me
all right up or down
Shh Ola do ladakh keep ilanic off a
couple on a bigger bomb there we go well
baby how she penetrated me that's what
this no I didn't I can't even blink
whoa come down come down Marilyn Oh
don't lick oh don't ever they lick me oh
no Marla Maura come on may not pass the
plate
like a nipple shot if your nipples on
your waist back up I killed all your
brothers and friends too much so I guess
I gotta go in here
and of course I didn't have to Oh
everyone just calm Co everything's gonna
be all right
thanks I whoa what the hell are you
room as dad no it is bad what is he
doing that all right I'll see you I got
a replated
all right we are back I just killed
Facebook you can thank me later
now here comes the problem with rooms
not just calm down calm down we love
who's that with him I never actually
thought I made meet your uber Stan damn
you're sexy
I'll begin oh you gotta shoot him in the
dick that's why that's my Echenique you
whoa calm down door one budge someone
would totally knock it on it
maybe that that is creepy
just shh-shh haha alright another room
is that and the deck and then you run ah
[ __ ] I don't have any more amiable
that's it we're not problema
I just quite don't remember what am I
supposed to do oh no oh no oh look at
that
okay I found my room is jad they're
quite rare it looks like if staring into
oblivion
I see if we can get closer alright
nightly as you can see this is quite
splendid Rubens dad let's get everything
that one can nina see if I can get any
closer he's got a really nice butt going
on there very nice would be dad anak
talaq talaq cat-eyed what's baggage
which squares that just means you're
doing it right very good
there we go that's how that's how you
kill it oh no
funny thing about ribbons [ __ ] said
they're usually coming out in packs
there we go there we go there we go
that's how it's done that's how I roll
that's how I whoa whoa lady knit
anything okay whoa whoa whoa whoa
everyone does take a shell Bell everyone
calm down you're a bad you should be
happy I told you about this five minutes
ago holy Cooper holy crow corner all the
crocodiles save a box Fox and ducks well
I'll be damned I wouldn't take em all
right let's see if we can do it is
business really really span among us I
don't like one dancer you did going on
Justin Bieber never get Jaime Oh a lot
of people take seriously when I say
anything about JB like if you ever need
even if I [ __ ] do you even die I
can't waste that much Emma anything like
it's obvious I joke about is like oh
yeah I know respect for you ever since
you said
I don't care respect
oh I don't think as you can actually
make this I am pretty cool alright baby
oh yeah whoa why saw tonight sir watch
hi some girl who killed me what did that
how was that I want to know what was it
huh oh you shoot me
why you shoot at me wanna toss that
[ __ ] ass right don't
well I missed you take a good miss I
just miss I hear chainsaw guy to the
left to the left to the left
everyone here is Shane Sonja to the left
please do that Lee ah god damn it
luckily I have this console thumb
seriously though if I wasn't Korean hey
chainsaw guy what are you doing crazy he
crazy
he doesn't wait for me changer guy
change Booga croc oh honey I was going
to do it wait was it for Oh
down squeeze your my use of fat when is
there's an insomnia pocketed your home
you'd read that you were flexing your my
bra I come at me bra can't do it he
doesn't know how to open door oh [ __ ] me
are you kidding me this is this a
[ __ ] are you serious
man all right Evelyn this episode here I
am sorry I hope tomorrow I feel better
and I can actually record some decent
stuff for you breast anyway and that's
pretty much it
like beverage in yards just gotta cover
bread today now see you tomorrow mega
stop not yet out of all places Megan Fox
oh look at this I have a narrow deck
hell's ones having a the old bike what
are you doing